-We're back with Wanda Sykes,
everybody.
You have a new scripted podcast
with my dear friend Colin Jost,
"Trust Fall."
This is ten episodes on Audible.
Your first scripted podcast,
I'm going to assume.
Did you enjoy it?
-I loved it.
-That's really fun.
-Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
You know, because it's like
how when you do a --
you know, the animated movies
and stuff like that,
it takes forever for them,
you know, to actually see it,
to actually see it.
-Right, yeah.
-So this is so cool because
you go in, boom, boom, boom.
-The next thing you know,
it's out there for the world.
-Yeah.
-You play somebody
who's catfishing Colin Jost
is that --
I would say, of all my friends,
most likely to be catfished,
-It's him.
-Just in real life. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I think he'd still land
on his feet
and it would all be fine,
but he does --
He's a very, like,
trusting soul.
-Yeah, he has that faith,
that gullible -- trust--
Okay. We'll go with trusting.
Yeah. Gullible.
-Gullible works.
-Yeah.
-I feel like if you
professionally catfished people,
you would see Jost.
Even if you were watching "SNL,"
you'd be like, oh, him for sure.
-Yeah. Right.
Yeah, absolutely. You would drop
what you were doing and go,
"Oh, wait a minute.
This guy." Yeah, yeah.
-You would, like, mid catfish,
you'd be like, "I got to go.
I'm also not who I said I was.
I got to go catfish that guy."
-[ Laughs ]
-This is very exciting.
"Curb Your Enthusiasm" is
coming back for another season.
You've been fantastic
on that show
over the years.
-Okay.
-Did you have --
Was that a part you had
to audition for, for them?
-Okay, they tricked me
into auditioning.
-They tricked you.
So maybe you could be catfished.
-I hate auditioning.
-Okay.
-I don't like to audition.
For one, I stink at it.
Yeah, it's not like
I think I'm good.
-I'm really bad.
I was really bad.
-No, I've had -- I've been in,
like, a casting session
and had papers, like,
snatched out of my hand.
Like, we don't even want you
to have the script anymore.
-Wow.
-Yeah, yeah.
I'm not good
at auditioning, but --
So a friend of mine, she was
producing "Curb" at the time,
and she said, "Look, I really
want to get you on this show."
You know, I said,
"Well, you know,
I'm not going to audition."
She said, "Okay, well, don't.
Just come by me, Larry.
We're shooting down
at a car dealership today.
Come by and you can meet them."
I said, okay.
So I get down there
and I walk in, and I'm like,
there's a lot of black women
buying Toyotas today.
Why?
This is weird.
So then she said, "Wanda,
come on in," right?
So I go and I meet him,
and we're just talking.
He goes, "Okay,
so you're out walking and --
and I'm just going to say,
hey, I know that tush anywhere."
And I was like,
"Why the hell would you say
something like that to me?"
And he's like, yep,
she's got the job.
[ Laughter ]
-So that wasn't really
an audition.
You just had to be Wanda Sykes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So that's very helpful.
Well, it's a good fit.
and I will say, like,
that is --
I respect his process.
He knows exactly
how to get the right thing.
And it's a great show
because everybody's just
a natural version of themselves.
-Right.
-You also have "The Upshaws"
coming back.
That's really exciting as well.
This is a show that is really
exciting and means a lot to you.
-It does.
Yeah.
The show with Mike Epps
and Kim Fields, and yeah,
it's you know, it's a good old
throwback multi-cam
about a working class family.
And I love doing it.
And I love that, you know,
we're coming back. So, yeah.
-Well, congratulations on that.
Congratulations
on the podcast.
So wonderful
to see you as always.
-Thank you.
-You guys, that's Wanda Sykes.
Everybody,
"Trust Fall"
is available
on November 30th on audible.
We'll be right back
with Taran Killam.